Rio de Janeiro, Brazil, has some mesmerizing natural sights.
In addition to the beaches, hiking trails and mountains,...
...there's a man-made attraction that shouldn't be missed.
The Escadaria Selaron is a set of stunning outdoor steps...
...comprised of colorful tiles.
Created by the Chilean artist Jorge Selaron,...
...he began renovating the stairs in 1990...
...and finally completed the work over 20 years later.
The 250 steps are in front of what used to be Selaron's house.
It began as a sort of hobby, since painting was his first priority,...
...but the tile stair project soon took over as his main interest.
Monetary funds were a major issue with the project.
Selaron didn't have any assistance from the city.
He began collecting old bathtubs and using planters.
Over time, neighbors and residents began donating tiles,...
...which represent cultures from around the world.
Eventually, the vibrant steps were completed,...
...covered in blue, green, yellow and red tiles and ceramics.
Even mirrors were added.
More than 2,000 tiles from over 60 different countries were used on the stairs.
Next time you happen to be in Rio de Janeiro,...
...be sure to check out these steps, along with the city's stunning landscape.